and we will be counting down to 2022
across four time zones this year the
show is going to be hosted by comedian
michael yo an actress and movie critic
nikki novak so we wanted to get to know
them just a little bit more before the
broadcast so we had them interview each
other so this is pretty cool what me and
nikki are going to do right now and we
don't know what's going to happen we're
going to ask each other questions so you
guys get to learn about us and we get to
learn about each other we've actually
known each other for a very long time
but we have not prepped these questions
they're going to be spontaneous and
we're going to hopefully find out things
about each other that we've never found
out before okay ladies first
gentlemen first no ladies first oh
darling okay i'll go first michael yo
yes what is your favorite movie of all
time hands down
gladiator it's the best gladiator
russell crowe is the best movie out
there because
every time it's on
no matter where it is in the movie i
have to watch it so nick you know that
what's your favorite food and why a
hamburger and french fries but i really
favorite most food
my favorite food is french fries i
cannot see a fry and turn one down and
sometimes i'll say to myself nick
order a salad yeah
and get inside of fries no you know what
i can eat the salad first and then
you'll need a few fries it never works
out no you eat all right here's what you
do you want to know how to do it you
don't order fries at all you go to lunch
with a person and say can you order
fries and you just pick at their fries
so i got a question best new year's eve
ever
sometimes
it's the quiet ones that i like but i
would say the most spectacular new years
i ever had was in sydney australia whoa
i was down at the harbor bridge and it
is so beautiful i'm sure you've seen it
on tv it's amazing how about you oh
hands
down
about
20 years ago when charles barkley played
for the houston rockets i went to his
house i got invited to his house for a
new year's eve party
at midnight he opened up the
refrigerator and it was nothing but
chris stahl all in the everything oh it
reminded me of living in a snoop dogg
video it was insane that's the best new
years i've ever had
no
he has and the second one is
that is the first time
on a cruise in hawaii i told my wife i
loved her right at midnight new year's
eve gave her her first uh i love you so
she would remember it and i made a wait
nine months for it i wanted her to
remember that for the rest of her life
shout out to claire what's up claire
claire what's up
and you can watch michael nicki and
country star scottie mccreary on
countdown to 2022 on new year's eve
starts here at 8 58 right here on
channel 8 and of course we'll bring you
celebrations from all different four
time zones